Welcome back everyone this be my brand-new
marvel Hawkeye trailer video.
They just dropped some new footage so I'll
explain what's going on with the schedule
and the episodes.
They changed a couple little things.
But there's a bunch of Easter eggs here, and
this is all going to be overlapping with what's
going on with Spider-Man No Way Home.
If you're brand-new to my channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes I will
be doing full episode videos for this Jessica
did for the Loki series for Wandavision for
the other marvel Disney plus series and we've
also got new Star Wars episodes coming before
the end of the year too.
So I'll explained that at the end of the videos
well.
When we get closer also start the giveaway
for Disney plus memberships again to but the
big surprise here is that they're releasing
the first two Hawkeye episodes together on
the same day because if they didn't do that
a lot of you did the math on this their six
episodes in Hawkeye they would've originally
had the Hawkeye finale releasing on the exact
same day is episode one of Amanda Lorient
spinoff book of Boba Fett, which is releasing
on December 29.
This also this meta-Easter egg with the whole
Christmas of it all this going on during the
trailer.
So during the Hawkeye trailer.
The big conceit is that he's trying to get
home in time for Christmas.
Like this is all leading up to the Christmas
holiday.
Like in the last trailer.
I talked about how they're going for very
diehard kind of vibe because is taking place
around the Christmas holiday.
Like diehard to with him trying to get home
to his family for the holidays Hawkeye try
to get home to his family in time for Christmas.
So the marvel people also kind of wanted the
Hawkeye finale to air December 22 the Wednesday
right before Christmas.
So that's a twist would make sense that Hawkeye
would inevitably make it home to be with his
family on his farm for Christmas.
So now because they're doubling up on episode
one and episode two on the same day.
The finale will air right before Christmas.
So even though yelena belova is going to do
everything in her power along with Maya Lopez's
echo in the New York City Mafia.
Like the tracksuit Mafia from the comics to
kill Hawkeye.
It sound like they won't be successful and
he will make it home alive all these twist
does make it seem like he's wearing a little
bit of plot armor.
But I think that's the whole idea.
Like the not killing off the Hawkeye character.
Even though this is whole thing with him feeling
guilty about letting Natosha sacrifice herself
and him not being the one to sacrifice himself
on vormir, they actually address that during
the marvel what if episodes.
There was a what if episode in an alternate
universe where Hawkeye is the one to sacrifice
himself.
It was meant to be a big twist on the avengers
endgame scene with black widow the other cool
connection to Spider-Man No Way Home and what's
going on during the Hawkeye episodes.
Because is all happening on the Christmas
holiday is that Spider-Man No Way Home in
real life is hitting theaters right before
the Hawkeye finale.
And even though we didn't really see it in
the last Spider-Man No Way Home trailer some
of that movie.
Just based on footage and scenes that we saw
while they were filming seems like it takes
place during the holidays because it's snowing
in this scene when Tom Holland's Spider-Man
is walking down the street to find MJ later
in the scene when they were filming you find
that she's working as a waitress inside the
store here when we saw that we didn't really
know what was going on because we had learned
about the doctor strange of it all with him
completely messing with the multiverse tying
together a bunch of different timelines sewing
it together so that people would forget that
he was Spider-Man.
So we'll talk more about what's going on with
these characters we get our next big Spider-Man
No Way Home trailer which cannot she happen.
Pretty soon, but it just seems like what's
happening here towards the end of Spider-Man
No Way Home at some point during the plot
is also happening concurrently will Hawkeye
is also running around in New York City with
Kate Bishop.
But the other funny thing you see from this
new Hawkeye footage is that they totally saw
all your comments and questions about Laura
Barton no joke.
There were a significant portion of people
on my Hawkeye trailer videos last month the
thought that something terrible had happened
to her because she wasn't anywhere in this
footage the footage here.
Just confirm my theory that she did not come
to New York City to see the show with Capt.
America is Hawkeye tells Kate Bishop later
in the trailer and take my kids to a show
in New York City and have some fun for the
Christmas holiday.
So Laura Barton is fine.
Nothing terrible has happened to her and they
lose joke on the phone like Owen sound like
a getting to couple more days in the city
is like a better make it a couple if it wasn't
clear because it's been a hot minute since
we've actually been to Hawkeye's farm in avengers endgame
His farm is actually way back in Missouri
he lives in the Midwest his farm is in in
New York City, or anything like that.
So when he says he brought his kids to New
York City for the show for the captain America
musical Rogers that means they took a flight
and it was his whole big thing.
We also see way more scenes from that Capt.
America avengers musical the reason why it's
called Rogers is because it's centered all
around Capt. America's life.
But most of the footage of the actual play
that we see in the trailer is from the events
of the first avengers movie.
If it wasn't clear like you see Iron Man flying
up.
Like he's flying up into the chitauri portal
to close as they can bring the rest of their
fleet through and I love the way the Hawkeye
reacts all this to like you see the look on his face
If you've ever seen avatar the last air bender
is like the ember island players episode where
team avatar has to watch their story of the
previous episodes, be told in play form.
It winds up making them realize how awkward
and cringy some of the things that they did
were like Sue go trying to capture Ng all
throughout season one and they have almost
the exact same reaction to it that Hawkeye
is having here watching the play version of
the first avengers movie like wait a minute
what when that last Hawkeye trailer drop.
There were so many people that saw this scene
of fake Thor and thought that somehow this
was secretly Chris Evans cameo being inside
the Hawkeye series is another character.
But I believe they bury confirmed that this
is not Chris Evans is just somebody who looks
kind of like Chris Evans is a bunch of new
scenes with him in the back of that With Kate
Bishop I'm assuming just based on the way
the series seems like it's playing out that
she either doesn't start using the Hawkeye
name officially until the next project.
She appears in.
Like the next Disney plus series or Clint
Barton Hawkeye tells her she can use the name
at the end of the finale.
Because the whole joke here is that he catches
her inside the ronin costume and she's going
around New York City being a vigilante pretending
like she's the ronin character that the mobsters
have been so afraid of since avengers endgame.
That's what Hawkeye's talking about when he
talks about his past coming to bite him in
the ass having this reckoning because during
that five year time jump when he was going
around the world is ronin.
He was mostly going around killing all the
Mafia members who survived the snap is some point
I think is just implied that he threw away
the costume and somehow Kate Bishop found
it and start using it is just part of her
comic book origin story way she tries to be
a vigilante inspired by Hawkeye's actions
early theory the way they adapt her origin
story is that at some point during that five
year time jump.
She also was not snapped and when Hawkeye
was going around his ronin he inadvertently
saved her from some Mafia members and that's
what inspired her to become a vigilante like
Hawkeye Ronin the minor change in the comics,
is that he wasn't Ronin when that happened,
but he did the exact same thing in the comics.
And that's why she wanted to become like Hawkeye
but she didn't start calling herself Hawkeye
till after the Matt fraction run when they
were training together and that's what most
of the series exactly based on is that Matt
fraction run you could post all your theories
in the comments about which new marvel movie,
you think that show show up in next.
Because the whole idea is the marvel Disney
plus series are supposed to feed into the
movies like the characters will appear in
the movies.
Even though there positioning the tracksuit
Mafia is the main villains of the Hawkeye
episodes per this trailer really is meant
to be something deeper going on with Kate
Bishop's family because her mother's being
played by Vera Farmiga and she does not play
small role, so I'm assuming they'll be a change
in the comics, there's Maia Lopez's echo character
who gets hired by the mob now.
The rumor is is the kingpin is also going
to have a cameo this.
Like the daredevil Netflix version of vincent
d'onofrio's kingpin.
So for talking about who's really pulling
the strings behind all this Mafia stuff in
New York City.
It really would be him in with all the Maia
Lopez echo stuff, we arty know that they're
doing a full-blown spinoff for that in if
you didn't see my previous video was being
reported right now is that the plan is for
marvel to bring back the daredevil Netflix
characters for the Maya Lopez echo series
in a supposed to feel like an unofficial kind
of daredevil season four and then though set
that up for a full-blown daredevil revival
series on Disney plus we haven't seen him
in the trailer.
But one of the other classic Hawkeye villains
from the comics is supposed to be in this
cold swordsman and I think that he supposed
to be working with Eleanor Bishop Kate Bishop's mother
That's why there's all these theories about
Kate Bishop's mother being one of the secret
villains of the series supposedly.
Madam Masque is also supposed to appear during
the series as well.
So either that could be a new character or
Madam Masque could wind up being Kate Bishop's
mother this scene of Hawkeye going full iron
man working on this piece of hardware here
looks like him just working on one of his
trick arrows are one of his bows is because
the way they set up this big joke with all
of his trick arrows later in the trailer weight
were out of regular arrows trick arrows have
long time been a staple of the Hawkeye comics
going all the way back to the classic comics.
But you don't really see a ton of them in
the avengers movies in the MCU.
But he has used trick arrows in the movies.
On occasion woman get more footage all talk
more about what's going on with yelena belova
and Val because they were all expecting a
Val post credit scene where she shows up any
the recruits Maia Lopez's echo or his has
something to That scene of the black widow
post credit scene.
Clearly somebody want Hawkeye dead inside
the US government everybody get hype also
will I was working on this Hawkeye trailer
video Tom Holland made is big Spider-Man No
Way Home announcement about how it's basically
the end of Spider-Man as you know him right now
They did a brand-new preview for the movies
will do a big break out of that explain what
that means with the future Spider-Man is in
my next video that should post tomorrow everyone
click here for that new marvel daredevil announcement
to learn about him coming back and click here
for that brand-new guardians of the galaxy
3 Adam warlock announcement.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!